foreign
[Music]
good morning everyone
welcome welcome to next
Welcome to our session on how to use
vertex Ai and its generative
capabilities to accelerate your projects
we're super excited to have you here
I'm Jason
I manage several of our AI projects here
at Google cloud and I'm here with Eric
he's the vice president of data science
at Estee Lauder
we've got a packed agenda for today's
session
we're going to start with an overview of
vertex and where it fits into our suite
of products
including all of our newly released
generative AI capabilities
then Eric will tell you about how Estee
Lauder works with vertex to deliver AI
enable solutions for business
stakeholders
well come back to me for some Demos in a
deeper dive into some of our most
exciting new products including vertex's
model Garden
we'll talk about how it's a starting
point for your AI Journeys
and then we'll save some time for Q a at
the end
let's get right into it
so Google Cloud provides customers with
a complete set of capabilities and
solutions this is a diagram of our
technology stack
if you look starting at the bottom
we have some of the world's best and
most differentiated infrastructure
including our GPU which has a very
compelling price performance ratio
we also run GPU as many of you saw from
the from the keynote that just finished
with uh with Nvidia as well
one step up and we'll come back to this
in a lot more detail is our model Garden
where we offer open source Google first
party and third-party models
this is the starting point for your AI
Journeys it contains a curated set of
many of the models we use for Solutions
up the stack as well
this year we've extended the
capabilities of our AI platform
which has traditionally been known as
vertex
for training and hosting models we now
have
tuning distilling evaluating your models
we also have extensions and connectors
and then we'll come back to this as well
for for a brief second around grounding
later on
a lot of these are new announcements
this week and I encourage you to join
the breakout sessions that are going to
dive into each of these in detail
as we move further up
we have capabilities for search and
conversational AI
some of our agents so our AI Solutions
provide Solutions out of the box for
things like document understanding
Financial Risk tooling like and
anti-money laundering tooling
and also conversational interactions
we've integrated responsible AI tooling
up and down the stack as well so each
one of these products come with built-in
responsible AI tooling
and we're also proud to work with our
partners to deliver Solutions across our
entire ecosystem
I'd love to introduce Eric to come talk
about Estee lauder's Journey
it's the wrong direction great start oh
all right hello everyone my name is Eric
Higgins and I'm here to talk about sorry
I'm here to out here to talk about how
the Estee Lauder Companies is using
Google cloud in order to Delight its
consumers in the um and the the luxury
Beauty space
[Music]
now most of you did a bit of a business
perspective well
probably familiar uh with Estee Lauder
but many of you are probably not
familiar with all the brands that are
under the Estee Lauder umbrella
um so here's a little list of them here
the srl companies are a collection of
brands that span Cosmetics fragrance
skin and health hair care and these all
of these brands have a unique value
proposition and voice each has a each is
distinct in their own way and that
distinction is essential to the luxury
experience that each one of these Brands
delivers
now
Our Brands don't exist in a vacuum and
much like the companies that y'all
represent
um we Face Fierce competition in the
marketplace many of the challenges uh
that are many of the challenge that we
Face are on the grounds of the
experiences that we drive with our
consumers things like client telling
online and digital digital experiences
omnichannel convenience and of course
keeping up with um the ever-changing
trends in the beauty industry as well as
the fashion industry
success on these fronts means
demonstrating Excellence not only in
commercial activities but in operations
efficiency but also in the creative
disciplines through which we express and
establish our brand identity so pretty
simple stuff overall
now
the essay a lot of companies has a set
of guiding principles which actually
connect pretty well to the establishment
of a data science organization and uh
you know these I think translate well
both in terms of the goals that we are
trying to achieve as well as the
responsible development of the practices
that we're trying to drive
it's under these circumstances that the
a new data science team was formed in
2021 about the same time that vertex AI
was getting launched so we were kind of
co-evolving along with vertex AI this is
when I joined the company and I joined
to start a new data science team and the
equally new digital technology and
experience group at Estee Lauder the
team was to have a global remit across
all brands and
across all brands with a mission to
deliver
results-oriented data science and
analytics Solutions
demanded among other things flexibility
all of these diverse Brands operated in
diverse regions around the world and
they assumed equally diverse technical
approaches so flexibility was sort of
necessary in order to make sure that our
Solutions were generalizable
foreign
fortunately we were given the
opportunity to actually build a new data
science platform from the ground up and
doubly fortunately we were able to have
an exceptionally talented machine
learning leader join our team by the
name of Chris curro who actually had the
foresight to reinforce a system of a
culture of devops discipline throughout
everything that we did and he was able
to maintain this from the very beginning
until now and I cannot overstate the
importance of this devops discipline in
developing machine learning
opportunities and how much has been able
to drive what we're doing and how much
of that was actually enabled by Vortex
Ai and Google Cloud tools
so this is the the part of the
development philosophy that Chris helped
us reinforce
um actually in the interest of time I'm
not going to read the whole thing but
this is important because this actually
guides all of our developments and it is
actually empowered by all of the
services that we're able to draw from
Google Cloud it has allowed us to adhere
to these principles and develop in a way
that was ultimately scalable and
reaching that goal of generalizability
now in the beginning this meant using
open source Platforms in order to
maintain that flexibility that we need
to operate with all of our different
business units we were using open source
tools like Cube flow pipelines
um to build and manage workflows and
promote a you know when we promoted
rigorous systems of review and processes
in order to make sure that we were
sticking to that discipline that we set
out to achieve
uh gcp was our preferred platform and we
progressively used more gcp services as
we went along and again this might this
team that I'm talking about started out
at the same time that vertex AI was
launched so we kind of were
progressively integrating more and more
into our system of vertex AI Solutions
as time went on we were building out new
Solutions
now some of the earliest wins that we
had were in a b testing Frameworks uh
where we were where our teams were able
to develop um and deploy variant
reduction methods that actually reduce
costs and increase the speed at which we
could run tests uh we were also able to
deliver Advanced recommendation systems
tested a lot or something that I'll be
revisiting a little bit later as well as
consumer lifetime value models and
expanded customer segmentation now these
last two in combination with the a b
testing allowed us to deliver cost
savings early on to the sa Lotter
companies as well as increasing spend
efficiency for a lot of our marketing
activities this helped justify the
existence of my team by delivering a lot
of these early results and over time
gave us the clout to generate a lot more
demand from inside the company to
explore other capabilities using
artificial intelligence and machine
learning now vertex AI was a key element
of this we were using more and more of
these these services and so that we
could spend less time worrying about
infrastructure and more time thinking
about the data science Solutions we
wanted to build and how we were going to
be driving business value and a key
element of this is our development
partner evident who we were able to lean
on for staff augmentation they were able
to help us scale resources as necessary
as a Google partner but they were also
bringing in as a as an organization
that's familiar with Google Cloud
products Essential Knowledge that
actually furthered our journey in data
engineering analytics as well as a lot
of our machine learning efforts
so here's an archive texture diagram of
where we we're Landing now now vertex AI
plays a central role in all of this in
order to kind of keep things simple for
us and again keep us focused on a lot of
the the business deliverables that are
driving what we're doing
um on top of that we also bigquery it
plays a very big part in all of our
analytics initiatives a lot of our bi
and total data infrastructure is built
on bigquery and of course we use things
like Google artifact registry because it
integrates well with Google Cloud tools
as well as a lot of our CI CD tooling
um and that helps us automate a lot of
our Pipelines
so a lot a little bit more about those
use cases so Estee Lauder one of the
most important experiences that we have
on our website is personalization and
recommendations are a big part of that
so vertex AI provided us access to new
recommendation tooling systems that are
allowing us to deliver new ways of
actually doing personalized experiences
on our websites so over time we're going
to be deploying more and more of these
to a brand dot to our brand.com sites to
give consumers an increasingly uh more
personalized experience
um and how they experience Our Brands
and our products
more recently we've been able to explore
more uses in generative AI which I know
is something that's very interesting a
lot of people here but this actually was
not a new area for us uh that guy
mentioned before Chris curro actually
back in the middle of 2022 he led a
small team including an intern to use an
llm to actually help us get a better
handle on our customer care our customer
call logs in order to actually more
accurately label the reason why people
were calling and this allowed us to
identify issues faster and ultimately
act on them faster so that we can create
a more seamless and improved experience
for a lot of our consumers
expanded on these use cases and started
looking at ways in which we could
actually produce reviews digest so
people provide us feedback on our sites
and feedback on our products and these
come in at large volumes it's very
difficult for our business stakeholders
to actually go through all of these and
figure out what to do so llms have
allowed us to summarize these quickly
which helps our business take you know
are the people on the business side
identify the issues act on them quickly
and again deliver a more delightful
experience for our consumers and make it
so that these types of issues don't
continue to prevent
foreign
we've also started looking at how llms
can actually accelerate a lot of our
creative workflows and workflows and
copy related activities uh primarily
through variant generation these copy
variants may be you know may be used to
substantially reduce the time and
turnaround time associated with a lot of
our marketing and strategy activities
again freeing up time for a lot of
people on on who work on those work
streams
the examples here were actually chose to
be completely inane so if you're
wondering why why is Estee Lauder you
know want to change the copy variant to
be a little bit more Sinister that's
just my team having fun and it's
something I can put up here without
being you know too risky
and of course more efficient and
accessible ml uh more efficient and
accessible ml environment has given a
bump to a lot of our commercial data
science activities allowing us to
deliver and iterate faster so overall
we're continuing to improve efficiency
the more we lean on these Frameworks so
all the while vertex AI has continued to
evolve and we're actually integrating
more and more into the way that we do
our work and it's actually creating new
ways for the all the people across my
team to interact with vertex AI both
through our normal mlops environment but
also through some of the no code and no
code capabilities are coming up on the
platform itself and with that hand it
back over to Jason to talk more about
model Garden awesome
thanks Eric that was really exciting
it's amazing to see how quickly you
drove business value right from the BET
and well we often see a lot of our
customers you get a big win to start
with and you can you can get a lot of
rope for your team to explore and that's
that exploration really drives the the
future of companies and so we're seeing
that all over so it's actually one of
the really cool things about our
foundation models they they work for a
lot of use cases right out of the box
and then they evolve over time as you
get more and more creative
speaking of which
I'd like to talk a little bit about our
model Garden
so
the model Garden is our opinion to take
on the best and most relevant Google
open source and partner models
we've integrated all of these models
with vertex's powerful tooling so you
can get started in seconds we'll show
you some Demos in a little bit
we enable end-to-end Journeys where you
can find the perfect model for your task
tune it for your own needs and then
deploy to a custom endpoint all in a few
clicks
our collection of models includes a
broad array of large Foundation models
and wide variety of more task specific
ones
model Garden is a great place to compare
whether you want to start building from
an API
or work from one of our up the stack
solutions that I talked about before
and of course the ml Ops tooling that
Eric talked about before integrates with
all of these models as well so you don't
need a separate starting point for
generative AI Foundation models that you
would for any other ml model it's all
integrated
so what are you going to find in model
Garden
we have
40 Foundation models
like Google's Palm 2 and Imogen
and we have 60 open source models and
these numbers are growing every time we
do another release so we started a few
months ago and we're up 30 percent from
70 total to over 100 total now
we are committed to providing our
customers with Choice while we're very
proud of Google's 1p Our Own Foundation
models we're also committed to providing
our customers with the choice for the
best models for your workload and we
still want to have that be seamlessly
integrated into vertex
Google's been working on AI for quite a
while now so we have some task specific
models that we've also developed and
those are available in model Garden
things like optical character
recognition Google created a very good
OCR algorithm when we scan the world's
books and we make that available to our
customers we've been working on it
consistently since then sentiment
analysis and then translation things
like it's the it's the algorithm that
powers the the free product Google
translate as well so these are some
really powerful world-class models that
you might not think about in the same in
the same thought process as you think
about something like palm2 but sometimes
these models are the right choice for
you and so we're committed to giving you
that choice
these models work across a range of
modalities like text speech embeddings
images
documents and more
one key Point here is that we think of
documents as their own modality
documents have text and images and
layout and so as we move over time into
a more multimodal world
inputs like documents are just going to
be thought of as another input format
that's distinct from things like text
and images and speech
foreign
so what's new today
for those of you who are watching the
keynote some of these were uh were
mentioned earlier
we have
20 new OSS models
so we've been working quite quite hard
on bringing the best to model Garden
so you'll hear about the upgrades to our
foundation models in the other sessions
this week so I'm not going to dwell on
on the Google first party models too
much let's talk a little bit more about
the OSS models and then our partner
models as well so as as Thomas mentioned
in the keynote we've integrated several
of meta's models into our model Garden
so llama 2 is now fully integrated and
we'll go into that in a little bit more
detail later we'll show you I'll show
you a little bit more of an example
we've also integrated meta's code model
so codelama
those were released late last week so
about 48 business hours later we've got
them up and running in model Garden so
we are committed to being at The Cutting
Edge of the best open source model
releases
this week as mentioned about an hour ago
we were also pre-announcing Claude 2
anthropics model as a pre-announcement
for it will soon be available and
integrated into our model Garden
so we offer first party open source and
partner models all in one place all
integrated with vertex's tooling
one thing that is particularly it's a
decision that we made is that we're not
just providing for the vast vast
majority of these models we're not just
providing a link to a repo somewhere as
an open source model that integration
things like responsible AI tooling
things like there's bias evaluation
tooling and then just pure model
evaluation comparing the results of one
model versus another model that kind of
tooling and integration with all of our
existing ml Ops tooling that kind of
tooling comes out of the box with model
Garden
let's go into some use case deep Dives
and for here we're going to do a demo
so I will let the team switch over and
turn my computer on
there we go
so as my colleague mentioned earlier
this morning we'll see how live demos go
you know it's live if something goes
wrong
so here you can see this is the The
Opening screen for model Garden when you
click on model Garden or Cloud console I
would expect that most of you who are
developing tooling for your Enterprises
would be building your own applications
to deploy many of your business users
won't necessarily be coming to the
Google Cloud console for the purposes of
demonstrating here I wanted to give you
all the the very bleeding edge look at
what we're doing
so
as Eric mentioned one of his use cases
is around marketing so we're seeing a
lot of marketing teams generate content
and a lot of it is fixing a blank page
problem right you show up at the
beginning of the day and I want to think
of four or five different options I
write me copy for each and let's go talk
about it edit it see which one the best
one is but let's get started it's
generative AI is really amazing for
those types of use cases
today
let's use vertex to generate inspiration
for a blog post for a healthy snack
product line at a consumer package goods
company so we need a Blog title content
possible hashtags and things like that
for social media sharing and then a
headline image so we're looking at
generating some text in some different
formats and also an image
so to get started in model Garden
we have Palm 2 right here I can navigate
and search
on top so I could search language or or
pick any of the other so once if you
don't know which model you want to start
with it's great tooling to start here
there are also filters on this
navigation as well so you've got
language Vision speech tabular data
documents video and you can look at
there's different tasks classification
detection extraction there's all sorts
of all sorts of options to start from
today for this task I know I want to go
right to Palm 2 for text
this is this is that you know it's live
so when you come to the come to the
model card there's a lot of data here
and I will make it slightly bigger I'm
not expecting everyone to read this the
point is that we're providing code
examples you can go right to API code
you can go to this evaluation so you
could run your test cents to get test
sets against the model you've got
overviews we give some detail on use
cases
and then we have documentation for
getting started including the command
line documentation if you're going to
use python as your as your programming
language
so for today I'm most concerned about
let's just generate some text right away
so here's where we can do some some
prompt engineering you'll see here again
I'll make this slightly bigger so that
everyone can see
so these are the models that are
available to you as developers obviously
you'd pick the right API endpoint to
bake into your applications here you can
work right with the the latest endpoints
and so we have some experimental ones
the latest one here knows that this is a
this is your non-version bleeding edge
release and then this zero zero one you
know it's a stable release so if you if
you choose to build an application on
top of it uh it's it's subject to our
generally available terms for stable
releases
let's pick the latest version of text
bison
over here there are some settings for
those of you who have been playing with
this I think some of these are going to
seem familiar we have some new ones as
well so temperature is a measure of the
creativity of the model
let's crank it up a little bit we're
regenerating fun text so let's let's go
wild
token limit tokens about four characters
so if you want to think about tokens you
can have uh these this endpoint goes up
to 8 000 tokens and then there's this
other endpoint here which is 32 000
tokens
so these are new releases and are
expanding our our token length from the
previous releases from before this week
as well
we'll go down here you can generate
multiple responses
two other
um very new releases as of today
so streaming so this is uh these models
generate tokens and so what you want
from a user experience the latency on
these models because they're doing a lot
of compute can feel like it's a long
latency so you can actually see the text
being written uh each token as it gets
output by the model so it actually the
time to First token latency and the time
to last token latency are very different
things so if you're looking here if
you're trying to make your users feel
like the model is running faster
you enable streaming
and there's another piece right here
called enable grounding
this one's interesting we released it we
just announced it about an hour ago
grounding for most of you who are going
to be dealing with the problem of model
hallucination there's a there's a
overall issue that these models have and
this the temperature control on the top
can helps to control that hallucination
a little bit this grounding here
lets you customize against your own
Enterprise data so return me an answer
that's consistent with do you have an HR
manual do you are you doing something
internal and do you want to give the do
you want to have an HR chat bot that's
the what are my 401k contribution what's
what's the employer match this year
which is different than what is the IRS
limit right that's a that's public data
this is your own company's data so if
you want your models to be responding
with item with with information that is
relevant to your own company's data this
is where you go first
for today we're going to do a little bit
simpler version of a of a demo
and so we won't we won't be grounding on
anything external but I highly encourage
everyone who's wondered
can we release something that's
consistent with our brand guidelines or
do we have do we have a manual for
fixing one of our Fleet of vehicles
again I want to answer questions against
it these are these are all real use
cases that our customers have come to us
with real life problems in in how we
developed our grounding solution for now
I'm just going to cut and paste a prompt
that I've developed where we want a
multimedia campaign to highlight
this healthy snack so we're coming back
to that original example
we've got a bunch of facts different
ingredients we're using grounding maybe
we'd actually have the recipe for our
granola bar we just put that into the
grounding source and also all of our
other sustainable practices
at the end I've just prompted for a
headline a blog post a caption and
hashtags
and
we will
I have to disable grounding there we go
now the submit button works
so I have streaming so you're going to
see the time to First token it's going
to be a few seconds and then you'll just
see the the content oh there we go
that's how you know it's live
we'll switch over
if I sit and talk for too long things
time out in the background too
um
so while this one reloads
okay
there we go
I hope the internet in here didn't stop
working
you've seen all the settings Let Me Wait
for this one to reload and let's talk
quickly about images
so for images
we have a model called imagine it's one
of Google's models first P models
I'd like to make a header image
so if I click on that
it's entirely possible the internet
decided to stop working just as I click
submit
want to run it off your phone again yeah
we can hotspot off my phone we were
joking about that earlier
um
let's flip back because I know we only
have a few minutes left so let's
actually let's flip back out of the demo
and let me uh let me flip back it is a
it is a sad State I apologize
um
we will
let's try one other time let's see if
it'll see if it'll come up yeah I'm not
we're just not getting anything at all
so
looks like we're having some
connectivity issues so
let's let's slip back to the slides
okay thank you
I chose to do one live demo everything
else on slides this happens
so for this one let's talk about a
digital assistant and let's let's decide
that we're going to start with metaslama
too so now available in model Garden as
we said before you can open up that
model card that I showed before to learn
more about it
we have another button right here open
notebook we released today we've
actually rebased our notebook solution
to be an Enterprise version of Google
collab so it's the the notebooks that
you know and love from collab are now
directly integrated with vertex
in here I can click
right on the deploy button
I pick the model name that I want for my
endpoint save it and it ends up right in
the vertex model registry
from there
one more click deploy to custom endpoint
that's how easy it is to get started
with llama2 you can get an endpoint up
in a matter of 10 or 15 seconds
but what if I wanted a more custom
solution what if I wanted to tune this
model with my own data so we've
integrated model tuning with llama2
within within model garden and right out
of the box so
to do this I go into notebook
and then I can
page through the notebook so I can step
through the that fine tuning notebook
and I can explore both parameter
efficient fine tuning and reinforcement
learning with human feedback tuning so
rlhf
we'll come back to those in a minute
so both tuning and deployment
are done within my gcp tenant where I
have full control and ownership of my
data
so it's an Enterprise Enterprise use
case your data is your data
I can also perform responsible AI checks
that are powered by the vertex content
moderation API right on the output of
the tuned bottle
for those of you who aren't familiar
with rlh it's one of the most powerful
tuning methods out there today
for rhef you have two data sets one's a
preference data set that lets you train
a reward model the other is a prompt
data set with unlabeled data think like
thumbs up thumbs down information from
your users
we feed your prompt data set
to the foundation model to generate
outputs and then we score the outputs
with the reward model assign a reward we
process this through the reinforcement
learning step to tune the foundation
model by updating the model weights
using the objective to maximize the
reward
at the end of the pipeline you get a
model that is learned to perform better
based on this human feedback it's one of
the techniques that's showing the most
promise along with so this one in
Perimeter efficient tuning of the two
we're seeing have the best results and
these tuning jobs are not particularly
expensive
as I mentioned before
we offer enterprise controls
for the models that you use in vertex so
your data is your data
for those of looking for those of you
looking to deploy generative AI in your
companies we've got everything that you
would have expected from any other model
using vertex also works for our
foundation models
we don't train with your data
we pass rigorous certifications to
ensure your data remains secure and
we're committed to keeping up with all
of the global regulation around AI
we also as Sundar has mentioned several
times we are bold get responsible so we
also have a wide variety of responsible
AI tooling
I won't get into all of these in depth
but I mentioned that content moderation
API think of it as knobs and knobs that
you can tune to restrict the outputs of
your models if you don't want the model
talking politics turn that down to zero
if you want that model to talk about
something else like a like a health
problem so if you're if you're running a
Consulting chat bot for for health
issues you can turn that up if you don't
want that you turn it down so we offer
16 different knobs
we have our built-in technical
safeguards we have checks to make sure
your model doesn't violate copyright
and then we also have bias evaluation
tooling so our teams our responsibly AI
teams have developed a pretty
sophisticated set of tooling that you
can test your model against many
different uh groups and we have some
really differentiated data sets right
now you'll see those are are running in
notebooks and we'll be progressing those
directly into vertex later this year so
the the bottom two are not integrated
yet with open source models and the top
two are
so I've gone through my my tuning step
and now I'm ready to deploy like I said
I showed before so now you've got the
tuned version of this model I can deploy
it right to an endpoint
we have time for one more use case
this one's pretty near and dear to
Google's heart it's around product
search so finding the thing that you're
looking for
a lot of businesses looking to help
customers discover cool products or
features really don't have great tooling
on their websites to help that happen so
there are some cool technologies that we
can combine
to create some really robust product
search so in this example say I'm the
chief data scientist for a sporting
goods store and I want to add this kind
of search capability to our online
storefront so that we can help our
customers find what they're looking for
in this case say I recently read about
something called text embeddings and
that's very interesting
what embeddings are our representation
of things like product descriptions so
Tech Snippets in a vector space
and so we can use the difference between
these vectors to understand similarity
so you're reducing the tech snippet into
a number
and then you're trying to see the how
far these numbers are apart from each
other essentially it's a little more
complicated than that I'm not a vector
specialist but we have some good tooling
out of the box to help you figure this
out
it's a two-step process first in model
Garden I navigate to embeddings for text
in the model Garden Tab and I can go
view API code
so what you're seeing here is text
embeddings gecko it's our highly
performant model for embeddings
I can use this to generate embeddings
and we have some customers doing this at
scale already it's one of our most
popular models
we want to pair this next with the
vertex AI matching engine which is our
managed Vector database
the matching engine has built-in support
for this Vector similarity thing that I
spoke about before
which is exactly these these two
together so you're going to think of
embeddings plus the matching engine
together can give you a really robust
and Powerful product search
couple examples
so the top rank product for pets is
table tennis rackets XL bright color so
if you're looking for to enable search
for your customers
this is where I'd recommend starting and
it and it uses a generative AI model for
embeddings
we also recently probably three or four
weeks ago released an image embeddings
model
so you can take the images on your
websites and also reduce them into
Vector space and search on them
this is the start of what we think about
is converging multimodal convergence so
now I can do the search on text and I
can do the search on image
so if you if you run a retail website
and you're looking to help your
customers understand red dress and you
don't have product descriptions for a
red dress this is where I'd suggest you
start I'd start with image embeddings as
well
take a look model Garden
stay here long enough for folks to take
a quick picture
the generative AI studio in model Garden
I promise your accounts will actually
work right out of the box it's only my
accounts that don't work
thank you